the Zelan dog distillery in eastern
Germany gets plenty of wheat from the
fabled wetlands it's been producing
crude alcohol for more than 130 years
yeah I ain't to movin is a minute the
proprietor is my daughter she owns the
whole thing the family arranged things
so she'd take over ownership and listens
in westwood not having the same time if
we can't carry on with the distillery
the way we have so far we'll have to see
what we can do with it eventually it
depends on the price trends when you
pile up the Zelan dog distillery now
turns out some three hundred thousand
liters of crude alcohol annually Germany
is the only EU member state to provide
guaranteed subsidies for crude alcohol
production now that's coming to an end
yeah I'm not about you liking it we've
run the numbers in Pakistan they produce
crude alcohol for 27 cents a litre in
South Africa for 34 cents those are the
average costs our sellin Dorf distillery
is top quality we may be able to produce
a leader for 70 or 75 or 80 cents so our
production costs are twice as high you
have to me a question d inched in zell
and off like most small distilleries in
Germany made its profits from the sheer
volume of crude alcohol the state bought
at fixed prices but for now the firm is
just keeping its equipment in running
order one option would be for zelanda to
cooperate with other distilleries with
producers of spirits for example to save
on production costs with Miss instilling
member mockney if we can't survive on
the market will have to shut down but we
don't have to cease operations that's
important several distilleries could
join together and try to establish
themselves on the market it's an
opportunity of course it won't work for
everyone but maybe for a few
for now the distillery is selling only
its own products and paying five
employees the bottling is automated but
the packing is by hand
not all distilleries in Germany have the
right to bottle their own spirits now
Zealand off is getting ready to supply
customers in the fabled region we just
wanted to make sure you've got all you
need or something's missing zelin Dolph
has plans to launch its own vodka apple
schnapps and kish that might bring in
just enough to keep the company going
the future is just as uncertain for the
farming operations the brewer grain a
by-product of grain alcohol production
has always gone to feed the cattle when
this issue i give this view with them
what if we don't get enough revenues
from crude alcohol I'll probably have to
get rid of the cows because they'll just
be too expensive our cows have just born
their calves outdoors will probably sell
them in autumn do you have must have
done some helps when you say that'll be
the time we decide when we start to feel
the effects of the new law whether I
keep the hurt or not will depend on that
the other behind the other without give
me other Zealand off is putting its
hopes in even more spirits producers
joining forces and in customers willing
to pay for the high quality of their one
hundred percent pure grain alcohol